la célèbre animatrice américaine oprah
winfrey est encore montréal après avoir
présenté une conférence au centre bell
hier soir et visité ce matin une école
de pierrefonds roxboro dans l'ouest de
l'île et kim c'est une surprise pour les
étudiants qui sont en pleine période de
d'examen c'est une rencontre donc qui a
duré environ une heure oprah winfrey qui
est venu rencontrer quelques centaines
d'élèves du secondaire ici au collège
dans pierrefonds roxboro
c'est effectivement une surprise sinceny
su que hier alors l'animatrice a répondu
aux questions des élèves pendant un peu
plus pendant environ une heure ce matin
leur a parlé de l'importance de suivre
leurs patients a souligné également le
travail des enseignantes et je voudrais
que lorsque la célèbre animatrice est
entrée elle a eu droit à une à un
accueil triomphant en voici un extrait
[Applaudissements]
à
les quelques centaines d'élèves qui ont
pu assister à cette rencontre ont fait
bien des envieux particulièrement chez
des parents ils étaient une trentaine
environ qui se sont réunis devant le
collège ici pour tenter d'apercevoir au
prix à son arrivée mais également à son
départ pour plusieurs sites une idole de
jeunesse voici une mère rencontre un peu
plus tôt si je suis une fan fini de
oprah puis je pensais jamais avoir
l'opportunité de l'avoir donc j'ai
manqué malheureusement sans sa
conférence de la fin de semaine hors jeu
très très content d'être ici a fini
l'école déjà la semaine passée mais
quand on ne s'y coop revenez régiront
elle est cool c'est un rêve depuis qu'on
est vraiment gênant toile a fait partie
elle a fait partie vraiment de notre
quotidien à tous les jours était sur nos
télévisions
elle touche tout le monde elle a
vraiment quelque chose de spécial
et tout ça s'est réalisé grâce à une
professeur qui m'a monté sur la scène du
centre bell hier valérie kamel c'est son
nom cette enseignante ici au collège et
elle parle régulièrement d'oprah winfrey
à ses élèves et l assister vous le
disiez donc à cette conférence hier et
bien l'importable rêve pour elle ces
produits aux profs à accepter neri si
les élèves sont en pleine période
d'examens foule dire et là il y en a
plusieurs qui seront en examen à 13h
alors le défi sera peut-être de
retrouver la concentration ça reste à
voir
merci beaucoup merci qui me permettent